all right I guess we're ready to start
this yeah I'm ready everyone still has
amazing avatars as always thank you I
tried real hard
is everyone ready to love everyone
forever oh no my my controller is still
on and it's just vibrating my lap for no
reason oh go oh no my mouse
oh no switch to the game no what I
pressed my goddamn controller oh there
goes okay well there goes the tingle
aberrations when did I get this many
cards wild card you only have 12 cards
it's fine
yeah you know but last time I looked up
I didn't have 12 cards and now I go why
are you trying to make the Botwin I'm
not trying to make the Botwin we're
never trying I'm trying to Botwin no
one's trying to make the Botwin why I
trying to make the Botwin no one is
trying to make the book all these guys
no marks animate the Botwin I'm not
waking the Botwin mark stop trying to
make the bot line listen I like the bot
the bot what is I don't remember what
that does if you play anything but
numbers you draw card Oh ball sex [ __ ]
well that's not a number oh nice oh nice
oh okay oh [ __ ] okay where's do I have
to declare declare
oh you know you know you think I'm
choosing this it's drawing it random the
whole game is random everything about
this is random I think it's currently
physically impossible for me to right
now no I said snow or blue and [ __ ] no
they're not they're white it's what it
see white snow have you ever seen blue
snow probably ate it and that's why
you're so dumb an opinion about this and
it's this one
oh why not want your car it's your car
alright I'm just I'm playing don't do it
I'm playing odds here cuz someone else
has got a card and everything's gonna go
rotate II okay oh jesus so good got mark
yes mark hard at heart of the cards part
of the car or the card part of the car
or the card part of the part of the cuff
part of the car part of part of the
cards
I guess I'd rather do this than the
other thing I have to do but to have a
real present to Reno oh okay well Wade
has a blue draw too so fake it sake
he'll make it blue
make it blue and stay true to you thank
you Mike
I literally couldn't make a hose oh part
of the cards cutie cutie has done
nothing this whole game duties as bad as
[ __ ] whatever her name Barbara what's
wrong with Barbara no Barbra run man we
all know Barbara did nothing that whole
time you were painting Barbara Isabella
Barbara didn't do [ __ ] Barbara didn't
paint rubber can't even Lance Barbara
had no talent I will say probably read
personal I felt that felt charged I've
been building up for a while
what did Barbara duty oh [ __ ] you turn
it up see topless I wanted to go you
know if you lost your words for a moment
there will turn eat up see topless yeah
well it's mark have does anyone know
what this marques who no I don't even
know what Mark has well let's right now
ha ha see cootie doesn't even know evil
idiot just didn't want to be as bad as
Barbara so cutie is on my better side
and [ __ ] Barbara listen I think we
just need to be nicer to the bots not to
each other be [ __ ] to each other I
don't know why everyone so mean to the
bots
they're just playing a win we gotta be
an [ __ ] about it
mm-hmm feel do you feel me do you feel
it I'm feeling you I've been feeling you
I literally can't stop whoa whoa that
challenge I I'm confused why you made
that sound but I guess we'll find out
okay I don't like this well that's fine
because it's not an eight from God for
no matter what but I gave you four now
for you just don't even know who you are
anymore
think about it I don't want to go like
this hand man I can't wait till I get no
don't I shouldn't be oh boy oh geez
swallow hey Mark how how much heart of
the cards do you have
not very much why why would we want to
punish you why to win it's been a long
day I deserve another win it's been a
long day you deserve nothing you deserve
nothing fine you know what here Bob
you're right and I feel bad so here you
can have it this is actually a good hand
- you're welcome
I know I just want to be nice friends
maybe then you wouldn't yell at me
anymore
part of the kind of the cards warning
there wasn't a lot I was gonna be able
to change about that this feels it feels
targeted I don't know it just feels
wrong you really literally handed that
win to me I feel like I'm just a
bystander that hole
game that was so weird we just played a
bunch of number cards and then ended
really quickly I just wanted Bob to be
happy well I do want Bob to be happy
when I said it out loud seven mice did
and I do mean Dennis right you said it I
you're too happy
I want listen my heart of my cards is
not here so [ __ ] you but I don't want I
don't want you to be happy to be happy
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not that I deserve Oh God oh [ __ ]
what is that one deal numbers only or
else you draw
numbers only [ __ ] mark you deserve
happiness to market okay I just want to
say I just want to say I'm glad someone
else has had that experience because
what you're experiencing right now mark
was like me the entire time we played
uno less [ __ ] life
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh wow what the [ __ ] oh no mark don't do
it don't do it like that I don't
remember what wait okay okay
[Music]
what do you you [ __ ]
I was clogging on all right whatever and
it still happened right good
ah before I do anything I want to just
go ahead and do this a little bit
[ __ ] that guy Yeah right more yeah part
of the cards
nice Nita Reno here mark I guess I'll
give you can have some fun because I
just got heart of the cards like that
would too much okay all Paul guess I'm
playing that Kitty or Q both it was
already blue yellow you can't challenge
it challenge it wait [ __ ] about the
rules I just want to play the game
where's your fun hallway sound effects
cards
[Music]
it has yellow it has yellow take this it
yes not so cute anymore are you
Oh heart of the cards is going on oh
yeah the heart of cards is right in
there feeling good now my sides hurt so
bad from laughing it mark that doesn't
make me feel better card side of the
card side of the cards okay alright this
is about to be so [ __ ] with the bots
having life for me I guess okay cool
that's a good one there some keepers
[Music]
I'd be the short step I have a gift for
you Oh scared
wait there's no way you don't have blue
[Music]
[Applause]
we all get a random oh I just wanted to
help
I just want to help yes
[Applause]
Wow you broke your audio setup you just
yelled so loud oh what a play by the bot
indeed I just want you to be happy mark
and I'm glad for you yeah my scream that
Molly's in the house what is this halo
jump oh [ __ ] now my hand was off the
mouse it's fine
I have 1/8 of yellow giving us your
strategy do you guys know about my a of
yellow I do oh you know about I'll have
a blue one
play that game mine is a [ __ ] bomb
not cool that's a bad color why would
you do that it's an above average color
[Music]
things that are blue your mood your
balls blue is great this is some kind of
problem I don't know what weight has but
it's oh hey buddy relax everybody calm
down
you know what
you know on it you don't want it Bob I
want it more than I want not it you
don't and you know what I'm so no I
don't know you don't make sound say no
I'm not knowing god dammit purpose
baby baby all right thank you my card
[Music]
no one compared my plight and what I've
been through to me don't compare myself
to me [ __ ] wait wait
boy challenge it's a liar oh boy it's
coming it's really happening
[Music]
[ __ ] what is happening over in wigs
alright I don't want to do this
necessarily but I don't want way to be
happy so okay it's my turn
well I guess there's a good time is they
see what happens okay that's not very
powerful oh but I have it never mind
[ __ ] I can't fall out or anything today
okay you gonna turn it was a double
bluff right a double bluff nice play
rough
that's rough bro bad play hi you got
here's my play play boom person to do
stuff to but I want to do stuff with
someone bad play play bad play
all right does anyone know what color
the [ __ ] thing has no no not a clue
it was your hand wait
yeah no clue oh [ __ ] you suck all right
one in four chance I can save it no but
I stopped them from maybe winning we
have to stop it Wow this color it's
undeniable it's unbelievable oh wait
part of the cards actually maybe green
discard no it's not
thank God no it's gonna pull fast one
like that on me not on smarty Marky I'm
gonna get some okay there we go that's
good one they don't blow safe look it's
we're just being a little too okay blue
is never safe blues bad boys bad [ __ ]
ass [ __ ]
alright that was alright to take back
the [ __ ] just [ __ ] ass good do you have
any offensive cards - why didn't you
play a bus - That's not me that's cutie
no cutie I cutie drew two cards last
time around because they drew a +2 thank
you thank you I think mark I don't think
Marcus blue I think we're good cutie
hasn't even won
entire time and luckily cutie what about
cutie [ __ ] it
her him [ __ ] UT okay yeah wait that head
really didn't have very much blue in it
this head doesn't really have very much
blue in it either fairly yeah definitely
gonna stay this color so that's good I
like that color that's a good color okay
good thanks bro yay thanks everybody
thanks me Torino oh you think that's
good wait till you see what I got I know
what you've got what because I'm a cool
guy
thank you see that actually helps cuz I
had nothing so that's good haha oh you
wanna you want some help mark I don't
like big fat one of those ok well that's
alright that's awkward because my next
play was to give me that hand
okay do anything about this I hope it's
not red it's not red who are you talking
to red scare everybody red so so [ __ ]
you fairly okay here I am adding back
I like that card that's a blue we have
this code system that we worked out
together cuz we double coming
scrambled eggs Mars tycoon your
scrambled eggs goes yellowing what are
you talking about clearly roller coaster
tycoon oh okay scram be eggs ride I'm
the fool here I'm funky cutie this I
guess [ __ ] you spaceship dick of the
cars
what is that oh that's what that is okay
I didn't I didn't have any choices red
and green that's must be what this card
is both ready Oh interesting both well
I'm about to know for sure what he has
oh look at that it's beautiful my urine
has never been so displeased I don't
think you know I don't know why I said
that or do you see a doctor maybe
Oh mark look at all those good cards you
got bye baby I'm a collector
Oh No oh you're in yellow mm-hmm you've
got people killer you speaking in code
you could just say what you mean to say
listen mark I can't get away all right
I'm gonna play the wait game does he now
okay no one change the color ever so the
bot the bot has only yellow left I
believe the pods raw why'd you do that I
don't like you Bob that's why marks
gonna hurt us I feel like that's badly
untrue yeah okay all right baby
Ernest I'm gonna hurt you guys he's
gonna hurt me right now
you don't know that I hurt him way don't
know I pretty good Wade mines pretty
good all right no one believes me that's
fine I've had this your mood you know
good six their way good six good six six
Wow that was actually a pretty good
sequence for me I still got a draw I
guess but that's okay Ron Karthus it's
fun to get new things you know it's like
I upgrade for my hand yeah
okay that's good that's good wait what
what what has more just curious I can't
do anything about it I guess but did you
have read I had [ __ ] read it's a one
party yeah that's a good one it's mostly
[Laughter]
[ __ ] your stupid [ __ ] hand oh dear
now see mark now no one needs to do
anything oh dear what's that to you
good play kitty could play good play
good play guys could play Thank You
kitty good play good kitty
see we like cutie oh yeah good job cutie
nice he's pretty cool cooler than anyone
else I know you didn't literally any
person in existence of this room you
know what mark yeah I want to see you
doing some more washing [ __ ] watch this
watch this you're gonna love this
are the guards closed what is that man
we're just as good or something problem
all right let's see it back up your
words back up your world oh do what you
do it [ __ ] okay all right listen
there there way it really even made
sense air kids watching I think we have
different concerns but mark and I are
both concerned challenging Wow challenge
it okay well that was a pretty thorough
[ __ ] Bob your hand I'm the hand man
that's me man Bob Oh mark look oh that's
a good one too oh you're talking [ __ ] my
hand is a nice one because it's not me
my hand should go commit all that
changes good cutie part of the car it's
hard on the cars
all right well funny joke uh Mike turn
okay all right okay
man I'm good how are you friends with
Mark and he's the one rooting for cutie
I'm not rooting for cutie Fruities work
mark was the thing is I'm rooting for
not you guys and it also happens to be
cooties here we're all
this might be the end of the game you
know it definitely is because it's calm
see wait this is why nobody likes you
[Music]
you